you know how like they all uh hired
their friends and family yeah Asian
businesses so it goes hey you you beat a
lookout okay I want to be the lookout
now you're gonna have to cut out after
her like why do I have to cut her legs
and you want to help me kill somebody or
buy a beer okay
[Music]
all right so this has been uh some
fairly big news that's been going around
anybody recognize the name Abby Choi tin
Fung no
how many names does she have that's
that's a lot right Abby Choi tin Fung
sound like a dumpling place it does
she's a 20 year old socialite and mother
of four who went missing on Tuesday two
weeks ago what makes her socialize she a
rich Chinese person I think she's like a
model in Hong Kong this is tragic I
don't know that was my next question
actually I thought social life was like
those really popular people that throw
events and they're just popular and
they're like Kim Kardashian Paris
Hiltons and [__] it's someone who
mingles in the upper tier of circles
yeah yeah
so um she went missing she was
apparently supposed to be uh picking up
her child from school at one point and
that's when she didn't pick up the child
that that was officially like she's
missing and stuff like that a few days
later uh I guess the the main headline
that kind of shocked everybody is that
the missing skull of her was found in a
pot of soup what the [__] they ate her
that sounds really wild but why soup
though I
does it say in the article yeah yeah why
not beef stroganoff what was the flavor
um they they deployed like dogs and
drones and stuff they're they're looking
in the cemetery searching in manholes
and stuff and police basically couldn't
find anything uh wait but how did they
find it in a soup somebody must have ate
it and be like this tastes like a human
and then they found it in the zoo the
discovery of her remains in a soup pot
answer the question Anthony I'm saying
right here it's a spicy it's a spicy
Revelation or was the soup bowl a helmet
so the skull just fit perfectly right
there dude these are again these are the
questions these are good questions this
is why JK exists you know
good question it's not it's not
it's not for sure already been covered
on every other Outlet right right but
people need to come here to get it's a
super perspective it's a soup served in
like a like a chain Dynasty Warriors
helmet you know because they oh okay I
was thinking motorcycle helmet they had
like plastic and stuff Harley Davidson
shirts or is it like a witch pot right a
big witch pot right a cauldron right
where they stir it yeah right they put
in like be that frog and [__] and like
yeah how did they even find it in the
suit it's it's getting there no no we're
never gonna get there let's bring back
the Qing Dynasty element because that's
not a Harley-Davidson
who ate the soup police found the least
police found toys dismembered legs in a
refrigerator and her belongings
including credit cards and ID card at a
village house on the outskirts of the
city three days after she failed to pick
up her child from school Chinese it's a
Chinese cannibal so it's in all
different places apparently it's in
different places yeah officers collected
evidence including a meat grinder and
Cleavers an electric saw black raincoats
gloves face Shields and two pots
containing What were later confirmed to
be human tissue and they weren't helmets
right uh I'm still looking we're looking
into that we might we might get into
that we asked Harley Davidson for
comments and they haven't yet helmets
Harley-Davidson in China so maybe they
do so we've been looking at the wrong
helmet company Triumph how about Triumph
all right uh police said they believe
the murder was carefully plotted because
the walls and windows of the apartment
were also covered in tarp and the
apartment was rented just weeks ago by
choice former father-in-law AKA uh the
ex-husband's dad
Troy's ex-husband Alex Quang was not
Resurrection uh was arrested at a pier
on Saturday
what you say his name after that dude
that's what you get for working here
when he was allegedly trying to flee the
City by boat carrying 64 000 US dollars
in cash and Patek Philippe watches worth
more than 510 000 that just sounds like
a champion dude going on vacation let me
see those watches that doesn't sound
like fleeing his brother was also the
chauffeur at the time who also got
arrested and the three men were jointly
charged with one count of murder Choice
ex-mother-in-law who was allegedly aware
of the plot was also charged with
perverting the course of justice so she
lied on their behalf so they planned to
kill her or was it a a ritual to eat her
I don't actually think they weren't
trying to either they were trying to
hide the body yeah I think they were
dismembering the like parts and trying
to figure different ways to they're
trying to dissolve because it sounded
like some black market human food
why why were they trying to kill her is
it uh for money like they were trying to
steal her money or like what's the
motive do we know yeah they said it's a
she complained too much it's a dispute
from they got after they got divorced
there was like some luxury properties
that were joint owned or something so
they they wanted control of it yeah the
police the police superintendent said we
believe the victim and her ex-husband's
family had many Financial disputes
involving huge sums someone was
dissatisfied with how the victim handled
her assets yeah
so you got to kill them if that happens
you know yeah yeah yeah you gotta get
those assets back
it's business yeah
still I'm still trying to see what kind
of helmet yeah
they went through that plot like the
whole family plotted to kill her that's
crazy that's a tight family huh think
about it this is Hong Kong right this is
Hong Kong and you own the land to the
only Ikea in Hong Kong right that's
[__] money right there and then you
got this stupid ass [__] that married
into your family she's not even a part
of your family and but she has like a
piece of that property she's cleaning
you out yeah you ain't getting no Ikea
for me fool do they own IQs I like
empathizing with the murders right away
because they say they own a bunch of
Kirkland companies it's just it's just
crazy that in American news like if a
family did this and they show the photo
it's like oh of course they did they
look like losers but then here these are
like Elite social people that are
pulling like dismemberments all of them
are social lights it sounds like it it
sounds like they're all well off they're
in the game but they're pulling they're
so well [__] yeah why didn't they just
hire assassin exactly
pay somebody off I know there's got to
be somebody right there maybe was a need
for suffering to be involved there's
nothing on taobao you can get for this
well maybe that's because Asians are all
they like to work their own business
they're too Hands-On like yeah
everything's family big
man exactly because if everything's
about money to this family and they're
like how much is an assassin
a hundred grand [__] that I do it myself
own helmet at home
and then you know how like they all
hired their friends and family yeah
Asian businesses so it goes hey you you
beat a lookout okay I want to be the
lookout now you're gonna have to cut out
after her like what do I cut a legs like
everyone's like that's some like mob
[__] you want to help me kill somebody
or buy a beer okay
better
[Laughter]
police bad days searching for missing
body parts only to find the skull in a
pot from the initial crime scene at the
village house that's great they found
the skull with the with hair attached
several ribs and human tissue that they
believe belong to the victim inside a
large pot of soup alongside radishes
more human bones were also found in a
second smaller pot why were they gonna
eat her dude explaining why they did not
locate the school earlier they said the
pot was filled with liquid and covered
in layers of coagulated fat oh so you
think they're preserving it like
pickling human
oh my God because I don't know if they
had that part just sounds like they're
actually gonna sell it in the black
market or something it sounds like it
sounds like the the fact they have a
meat grinder kind of looks like they're
trying to pass it off as like maybe
they're trying to dispose of it as meat
yeah so people don't think like oh that
was a yeah if we cook the meat then
maybe it's no longer and you just throw
it away that way it also sounds like
they've done it before like they tarp
the windows they have black oh I know
the experience kind of or they just
watch movies and they just try to be
like semi-sensible with something
insensible you know what I mean like
yeah I don't mean to be racist but then
like um any time I go to I love after we
were just going
it's okay they're Chinese
but I'm very sensitive about Italians I
don't want to hurt Italians right so
when I go to the Italian butcher
um they have so many delicious meats and
I love the bratwurst is that right is it
racist to say that they have buried
stirring but they have Italian sausages
God damn it [__] salami and all but
there's sometimes when I'm eating one
I'm wondering if I'm eating a mob member
wow
yeah when you eat like a Italian sub
right and you go and you go you know
what if someone what if it's veto yeah
what if they assassinated someone in the
back grounded up their meat and got into
the [__] sausages and I'm eating a
real live [__] member of the
corleones right now they always
dismember Mafia people and send them to
all the Quiznos yeah that's why that's
why the dude in the front's like for
Joey you get a special cut yeah see
we're gonna give you a special question
what if one of us what if we ate human
before we didn't even know damn I bet
there's a shot I've never thought I've
never thought of that I don't think I
have I don't think Chinese butchers you
know what you're getting because when
you go to [__] the place that's a
hanging duck not a hanging human right
but that's the thing is isn't that
culturally the reason why they hang
Ducks is because before they used to cut
up anything random and try to sell yeah
and then now it's like no no I want
thought you have to show me the top yeah
you see take it off the rack that's why
I like that because it's a [__] pig
you know it's a pig right it's not Pig
and fat Joni or whatever it is it's just
but they could just have the pig there
and put human inside the pig
feed the human to the pig Everybody Eats
the pig now you're exposing them well
I'd rather do that I'm sure there's
worse things we've eaten Than People
anyway man I had yoshinoy and Alvarado
once that might be human based those
broccolis are neon is does anybody ever
question the vegetables they're [__]
neon they boil it it keeps the color
it's it's just yeah when you open the
Starfall box of the sound
my food's talking to me
[Music]